did you miss i drew you  i'm davon rodriguez and i'm the most  followed visual artist on tick tock  today i have over 25 million followers  and counting  and in the next 30 days i'm going to  teach you techniques that will give you  the confidence to paint anything in the  world  so in this class i'm going to teach you  my secret techniques that i've never  taught anyone before  i like to smash the bristles it makes  the edges super soft and i'm going to  break down my process step by step  i'm going to be teaching you about  materials how to apply the colors mix  the colors how to blend your tones  together how to draw proportion  understanding light the importance of  reference photos everything you need to  know to paint the portrait  i'll teach you how to level up your  drawing and painting skills even if  you're just starting out so by the time  we're done with this class you're going  to have your own 9x12 oyu painting we're  going to have a lot of fun  [Music]  you